المترجم: Alaa Yasin
المدقّق: Nada Qanbar
(موسيقى)
(تصفيق)
جميعنا يسمع ويتحدث عن التغيير
التغيير من واقع المجتمع
التغيير من شخصياتنا
التغيير من السياسة، من نظام
النقل العام، من الطرقات
ولكن .. يا ترى ما مدى قابلية
وجهوزية المجتمع اللبناني للتغيير؟
سأتحدث اليوم معكم عن بعض الأمثال
التي نقولها في مجتمعنا حول التغيير
وتعكس نظرة المجتمع حول
هذا الموضوع بشكل أكبر
سأبدأ مع المثل الذي نتعلمه
جميعًا ونحن أطفال:
"عصفور في اليد، ولا عشرة على الشجرة!"
نفهم هذا المثل في لبنان بطريقة مميزة جدًا
على سبيل المثال، حينما يتقدم شاب لخطبتي
قد لا يعجبني كثيرًا
ولكن ماذا لو لم أتعرف على شاب آخر لاحقًا؟!
"عصفور في اليد ولا عشرة على الشجرة"
قبل أربعة أعوام، بدأت وظيفة
في الدولة في القطاع العام
وهي تعتبر وظيفة مناسبة جدًا
لامرأة مثلي: مطلقة ولديها ولد
أولًا: مواعيدها مناسبة كثيرًا.
ثانيًا: هي وظيفة ثابتة، ما يعني أنني
سأستمر فيها حتى أبلغ من العمر 64 عام؛
أي لا أحد يمكنه طردي من العمل
إلا إن قمت بمخالفة القانون.
كانت لدي مشكلة واحدة فقط متعلقة بهذا العمل
وهي أنه لم يكن هناك عمل!
(ضحك) أذهب صباحًا إلى الدوام
ويتم الخصم من الرواتب إن تأخرنا
أجلس ومن ثم أغادر وقت انتهاء الدوام
الشيء المنطقي الذي فكرت به
هو أن أبحث عن عملٍ آخر
لأنني لم أتعلم كي أجلس دون عمل.
من بين التعليقات التي سمعتها:
"ألا يعجبك أن تجلسي وتتقاضي راتبًا؟"
"لقد قدم الكثير من الرجال لهذه الوظيفة
وتم اختيارك أنت ومن ثم تريدين الاستقالة؟!"
آخر تعليق سمعته حول هذا الموضوع
كان خلال الأسبوع الماضي:
"ألم تكن وظيفة الدولة أفضل كثيرًا؟"
على الرغم من مرور عامين على تلك الوظيفة.
هناك فكرة شائعة في لبنان؛ وهي أن
أي شيء نتركه سنندم عليه لاحقًا،
وسنتمنى أن يعود بنا
الزمان؛ فنعود لما كنا عليه
هناك في لبنان أمثال أخرى حول هذا الموضوع
"من نعرفه أفضل ممن لا نعرفه"
فمثلًا، عندما جاءت الانتخابات، كان
هناك الكثير من المرشحين الجدد والقدماء
قمنا بانتخاب القدماء، ربما هم ليسوا جيدين
ولكن "من نعرفه أفضل ممن لا نعرفه."
(تصفيق)
في العمل مثلًا، قد يكون هناك من يتحرش بي
ربما يقوم المدير بالتقليل من احترامي
ومع ذلك، يبقى أفضل ممن لا نعرفه.
في البيت، ربما يقوم زوجي بتعنيفي
ولكن يبقى أفضل ممن لا نعرفه.
لماذا؟ لأنه "يكفينا اللي فينا"
ما يعني أنه يكفينا ما فينا،
فنحن نخاف أن نغيّر
فنقوم بتقبّل كل ما يتم فرضه علينا
ولهذا مثلًا، إن طلقني زوجي،
فكل المجتمع سيتعاطف معي
والعكس غير صحيح إن قمت أنا بطلب الطلاق
أو إن قمت بترك العمل، لا يتعاطف
معي المجتمع بقدر ما إن تم طردي من العمل
ولهذا، أرغب اليوم ومن خلال حديثي
هذا أن أوجه رسالة لكم جميعًا
إن كان هناك من حولكم أخ أو أخت
أو رفيقة أو زوجة أو ربما أهل
يفكرون بتغيير أمر ما في حياتهم
لا تخيفوهم من التغيير.
إن لم ترغبوا بتشجيعهم، حسنًا
ولكن أخبروهم على الأقل
أنكم ستقفون بجانبهم مهما حدث.
"يكفينا اللي فينا-"
مثل يذكرني بشاب أعرفه، هو في مثل عمري
ويعاني من فشل كلوي
ولذلك، هذا الشاب بحاجة
إلى غسيل كلى أسبوعيًا
مرّتين أو ثلاث مرّات أسبوعيًا
ومع ذلك، يقوم هذا الشاب بالكثير
من المغامرات ويتفسح كثيرًا
ويقوم بالسياحة، ويسافر
ليس لبنانيًا ولا يعيش في لبنان
لم أسمع عن شيءٍ كهذا في لبنان قط
دائما "بلا ما نكون بشي ونصير بشي"
ما لاحظته هو أننا نقوم بتصنيف
الأشياء في حياتنا إلى قسمين:
أشياء أساسية وأخرى ثانوية
يندرج تحت الأشياء الأساسية:
العمل والعلاقة العاطفية والصحة
أما الأشياء الثانوية فهي جميع الأمور
الأخرى التي لدينا استعداد أن نغيرها
حتى نتفادى التغيير في الأمور الأساسية.
مثلًا، إن كنت أشعر بالضيق من العمل،
فيمكنني أن أغير لون شعري
أو إن كنت غاضبة من زوجي، فأقوم بعمل ريجيم.
دعونا نعود إلى الأمثال
التي ضربتها قبل قليل-
لنفترض أن مديري في العمل يقلل من احترامي
وأنا لا أقبل أن يحدثني أحدهم بهذه الطريقة
من المؤكد أن الأسهل هنا
أن أقوم بتغيير ثانوي
وأن أقبل معاملة الآخرين لي
بهذه الطريقة وأستمر بالعمل.
أنا لا أقبل أن يرفع أحدهم يده علي
لذلك عندما يضربني زوجي
لأول مرة، سأترك البيت.
ولكن في المرة الثانية سأقوم بعمل
تغيير ثانوي وأقبل أن يضربني أحدهم
مازال هناك الكثير من الأمثال:
"لا تنام بين القبور، ولا ترى منامات سيئة."
"مائة مرة جبان، ولا مرة الله يرحمه."
"العنقود العالي حصرم."
أعرف أننا نحن في لبنان
بلد كابد سنوات جسام في الحروب
وعايش حالات عدم أمان كثيرة
ولكن لا يعني هذا الشيء أن نقبل
أن يكون هناك وظائف بلا عمل
ولا يعني أن نقبل التحرش أو أن نقبل
عدم الاحترام وغيرها من هذه المشاكل
لايزال هناك نقطتين أودّ تسليط الضوء عليهم؛
الأولى: هناك الكثير من الأشخاص من حولنا
يطالبونا بعدم التغيير لأنهم يحبوننا
ويخافون علينا، الأهل كمثال.
خاصة في بلد كلبنان،
إن طالبكم أحد بعدم التغيير فهذا
بالطبع لا يعني عدم محبته لكم
بل على العكس تمامًا
أما النقطة الثانية فهي:
أن التغيير ليس عصًا سحرية
لا شيء يمكنه أن يجعل
الحياة خالية من المشاكل
التغيير مثله مثل أي شيء آخر؛
له إيجابيات وله سلبيات
ولكن ما حاولت أن أنقله اليوم من خلال كلمتي
هو أننا نعيش في مجتمع لا يخاف
فقط من التغيير؛ بل يقاومه أيضًا.
أتمنى إن حاول أحدكم يومًا ما
أن يغير شيئًا في حياته، ولم يغيره بعد.
أن يعاود التفكير مرة أخرى، وأن يأخذ في عين
الاعتبار أننا نعيش داخل مجتمع كهذا.
(شكرًا)
(تصفيق)